thank you
[Music]
New Mexico is experiencing its largest
ever wildfire that is currently burning
and it started in April oh [ __ ] at this
moment it's still going on it's been
burning for like two months yeah man
how did it happen how'd it stop oh
you're gonna love this so it's covered
nearly 350 000 Acres please don't tell
me it's a [ __ ] gender reveal oh my
God
so is it a boy of course it's worse it's
worse what do you think worse than
gender reveal I think the cause is worse
you could tell me if it's not but I
think it's in April is it 420 related
worse worse how what could be worse than
a gender reveal accident a birthday
party
no that's better than that
they were trying to water it but they
watered it with gasoline that's pretty
good so it's the opposite of doing
something good right they're like it's
too dry here you know what's sad is
that's probably the closest thing really
wait is it one of those controlled
forest fire things that the uh fire
department does
um
prevent these things and they made it
worse so that's hilarious service
themselves caused it by doing two
controlled Burns in separate places that
went out of control and join oh yeah
I think it's a sign a bunch of homes
have been lost like it's going [ __ ]
nuts and it's they didn't realize that
there's a [ __ ] donut-shaped forest
homes in the middle
ring of fire
they were doing two controlled Burns
which of course you have to do whenever
like the brush gets dry and it's a fire
because they're like yeah it's a fire
risk it's gonna have to burn it but then
they didn't take into account a bunch of
different conditions that uh one of the
things they're saying is
um that they're kind of blaming it on
which sounds like is global warming no
they just sucked as firemen now you know
yeah you don't get to blame honestly
what's that yeah they became firemen
like they're the Pyro men do you know
the do you know New Mexico's nickname
what what I forgot what it was but Nuevo
Mexico no but it's something like um
like the stay here state or something
like apparently it's so beautiful yeah
it does look beautiful people like once
they move there or they pass through the
land of enchantment wow
[Laughter]
it didn't chance you to stay yeah people
move and they just or they go check it
out they test it out and they just stay
forever because they love it the state I
like it dude because like the the
sunsets they're [ __ ] out of this
world I mean Arizona New Mexico they're
kind of similar right yeah they might
really hate me about that because you
know how like they're like they're so
different but like for me when I'm
crossing through it's basically the same
[ __ ] but something happens when you're
going east from California past the
Mojave Desert yeah right so there's a I
think it's not the Rio Grande I don't
know what's that river that separates
California Colorado River maybe but
there's a huge [ __ ] river that goes
down to Mexico that splits the two the
four or five when you that's it
because everything east of the 405 is no
longer California
so like so so when you pass it
the desert changes completely like it
looks like a [ __ ] cartoon desert like
where you would see the roadrunner and
that it turns red [ __ ] cactus that
does this that [ __ ] Cactus is out
there yeah it looks like a real Cactus
the canned Cactus yeah and um and then
it's not as hot it's it it's like it's
it's not as hot as like our Death Valley
hot and and like you're about to when
you see a California desert it's like
that's where even the devil avoids you
know like you go there and you're like
someone's gonna die but then in [ __ ]
New Mexico Arizona it feels like an
oasis like oh
you're going to find a nice little
[ __ ] watering hole right here in an
enchanted naked lady and that ring of
fire yeah and a ring of fire that's what
they're saying is like a donut Ring of
Fire because climate change has caused
so much more of a drought in certain
areas that they don't have water to put
the fire out no they don't have water to
drink to have enough energy to put the
fire out yeah you don't have enough
water to like and put it in their mouth
and spit it back out at the [ __ ] fire
they just drink gasoline then
it's too expensive oh yeah so this fire
has been going on for two months and are
they like nearing an end damn dude a
fire that goes on for two months I mean
yeah it's insane if it's going that long
and it's spread that large I mean
they'll probably just let it burn out
maybe are there any cash of course it's
huge though I don't think that sounds
like the whole State's gonna Burn yeah I
think they're just like everybody's like
under Evac risk they're just [ __ ]
smoke everywhere there's Ash everywhere
what are the aliens gonna do at Roswell
yeah looks all cool and red if there's
what what are the aliens gonna do at
Ross well they're fireproof oh
I wish there was a way to like you know
we send all that money to like Ukraine
right is it a rebate we just sent
another 450 million dude
all that money to Ukraine to help them
in the war efforts I wish we could send
fires over there so you dig the forest
jeez and then you throw it at Russia or
something oh you don't have to spend any
money just like like what do they call
it upcycling these days you upcycle the
fire it costs like three billion dollars
to send a forest yeah well we sent 450
is Flowing on the ocean and pushed it
it stays on fire in the ocean
two months so you know you can't come
down
just
cut it off take the whole for his face
that used to be a [ __ ]
um War tactic you know that sending
fires across the [ __ ] ocean yeah they
literally two months they would [ __ ]
set little boats on fire and then just
put it up the shore is that Japanese
oh all over the world they did this
technique where they would cover a ship
in tar and then they would abandon it
just burn it and then that should just
have a big [ __ ] it's our own [ __ ]
burning ass ship coming up to your wall
you're like what the [ __ ] dude you're
like go the other way
that's weird so it's like a trojan horse
but just a burning one on the water I
imagine all the times in movies where
it's like a burning tar ship or not even
burning it's just a tar ship it's like
coming towards you and that one guy's
like with the flame Arrow but I feel
like I'll miss it like six times
you just keep seeing multiple tries yeah
right like you gotta calibrate global
warming I miss you because global
warming
I'm sweating yeah so there's people that
are pissed about that excuse because
um yeah it's such a vague excuse too the
way that they're like well it sounds
fake to me maybe because I'm not a
scientist but they're like yeah uh
drought extreme weather wind conditions
unpredictable weather changes all of
that's challenging our ability to um use
prescribed fire as a tool to combat
destructive fires so they're like
they're like the global warming changes
are making it hard for us to burn things
correctly
what the [ __ ] I don't know man yeah
because either way they they have to
don't know enough of that yeah they're
they're supposed to do that so it's kind
of like they can't just not burn brush
that's gonna burn later what's more
likely is it the fact that it's global
warming or they [ __ ] up
I don't know that's what I think I think
to be like that's why
you know they're still even with the
current climate changes if you know the
climate's changing then shouldn't your
tactic change with it
you know what I found out that was
um that was like oh [ __ ] I didn't I
didn't realize this was a big part of
the ecosystem that we needed but it's
gone now and that's not global warming
but that's an American buffalo dude the
American buffalo We Stand [ __ ]
millions of those [ __ ] roaming
free and they would eat up the grass in
the shrub and then they would control
that environment so then the whole thing
won't be full of [ __ ] you know big
brushes and [ __ ] oh the original firemen
yeah we don't got buffaloes no more I
heard there yeah
they got [ __ ] like they got [ __ ]
chlamydia yeah they be [ __ ] dude how
do you know it's a huge thing Buffalo
STDs are all the Rays right now I've
seen some buffaloes at Yosemite they're
pretty beautiful how did the Buffalo get
come in here
for a joke dude nah they got it from
each other hey how'd the Buffalo uh get
committed
from South Park dude you like Imagine
Dragons
that's a good one do you know the
punchline to that no what is it that's a
dude uh do you like Imagine Dragons yeah
sure imagine me dragging these nuts all
over your face it was Joe's joke it was
Joe Joe's bad one he said it was like
that I respect people
laughs
don't put Ebony's rap out like that you
got me for a wrong kind of guy what's
the what's the solution to this get
camels
it's called Let It Burn all right that
was yeah
no it's do you really want Mars
yeah they really are I don't know
because all they're saying is like okay
we're gonna do better next time kind of
thing while they just keep next
sorry they're just trying to put it out
but hey trees grow back right it's all
good
many fires as we've seen in California
there never really is a thing that they
say on for the Press here's how we're
gonna do it it's just we're gonna spray
water somehow you trust them I'm sure
there's a whole protocol that they can't
even like you know it's so detailed that
it's like boring have you seen those
massive fires and then you see the
helicopter come and you're like oh [ __ ]
finally he's gonna do something and he
[ __ ] dumps the water and it's like a
drop and you're like oh wait that's a
lot of fire is the land Mist the misters
dude that's like oh good this is great
yeah that that [ __ ] ain't doing nothing
dude that's a big fire imagine if this
whole time throughout history no one's
ever put a fire out it's just burned
itself done like this whole time
firemen fire departments or hoax they're
just acting crisis actors
it's not even real water water doesn't
even work on Fires it's all CGI dude
it's just like it's like fantastic
Graphics it's just a hologram it's
already watered with protection honestly
you can't put it out
but they just project more water so
everything is water there's no such
thing as fire it's amazing even birthday
cakes
damn yeah there's no real uh obviously
they're just gonna do their best but man
two months now 350 000 Acres they can't
just throw some dirt 350 000 that just
sounds like it's already going to the
next state and then at that point it's
like it's not our jurisdiction
problem yeah I don't even know what 350
000 Acres sound like that's not like a
state yeah
let's see what it's big that's like
bigger than Connecticut for sure I don't
know maybe that's like LA or something
we don't even know you know I don't even
know what the [ __ ] is an acre yeah what
the [ __ ] I could see one acre let me see
how many see what that looks like it
looks like is this an egg right here
that's about
I don't even there's nothing that even
there's no file big enough to show me a
photo
imagine an acre is like a cow like three
California homes from the backyard to
the no I need but what about I live in
L.A we think in square feet San
Francisco boasts a remarkable diversity
of open space totaling 5 384 Acres
that's it SF is five thousand how big is
Disneyland that might help me out can
you think of Disneyland
I think we should all do something
relatable like a [ __ ] Disneyland here
we go how many acres is Disneyland 500
how big is the Medieval Times what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am I doing here Medieval
Times is way smaller bro so 500 so what
like seven how many how many acres of
McDonald's on [ __ ] wait so 700
Disneylands then yeah how many acres is
the JK office
yeah 700 right no 500 700 yeah
foreign